The Joe Rogan Experience so with things
like funding the Ukraine war with Russia
please explain to people what that means
and why why we're sending so much money
over to Ukraine
um
so so let's start with with that let's
start with the military industrial
complex what is it who is it it is these
massive defense corporations who make uh
all these different weapon systems from
the smallest to the most powerful
nuclear weapons and missiles uh
when we are at War they make a lot of
money uh when politicians even if we're
not at War but are threatening that we
may go to war they make a lot of money
and these decisions are not made within
the context of hey what is our military
actually need what do we need to ensure
that our military is ready to defend our
country and our national security
interests it is uh very often what
members of Congress are advocating for
even more than the military is asking
for sometimes because of those relation
those cozy relationships with the
military-industrial complex with these
massive defense contractors and their
lobbyists so there's a direct there's a
direct correlation as the money is
changing hands there
um
the the problem is not with the
Democratic party the Republican party on
this issue and you see this so much
divisiveness on tons of other issues
facing our country everything from
infrastructure to education all these
other things you see like oh my gosh
Democrats and Republicans can't agree on
anything
this issue of
putting our country in a continual state
of war is supported by leaders in both
parties and the majority of people in
both parties and it's directly tied to
the military-industrial complex's
influence and tied to people who you
know want to act and look tough but
aren't asking the most important
questions like okay if we do this will
this help the American people or hurt
the American people if we vote to you
know send these billions of dollars to
Ukraine is that strengthening our
national security or undermining it
you'll hear a lot of rhetoric especially
recently saying hey if we we've got to
send all this money to Ukraine otherwise
Russia is going to come and attack us
here otherwise our National Security
will be undermined so they say all these
things to foment fear in people's minds
but they're not rooted in reality
so what we're seeing play out now is
essentially a proxy war U.S is engaging
in a proxy war with Russia using Ukraine
as their military so the U.S and some
European countries predominantly the us
though are providing billions of dollars
in funding weapon systems and so forth
and essentially waging this war using
the Ukrainian military and people as
their chess pieces in this geopolitical
um chess game the ultimate objective
being regime change with Russia and you
can see years before
um obviously Russia's invasion in
Ukraine uh this this anti-russia
sentiment has been building up by the
the permanent Washington establishment
and laying the groundwork and this was
the opportunity that they saw
um it's put us in the most dangerous
position we the American people and the
world has ever been in
in that we a nuclear war could break out
in a week in 30 days we we are staring
over the precipice of that nuclear Brink
now more than ever before
we're hearing language coming from Putin
from Medvedev from different Uh Russian
nationalist leaders saying no Putin you
should go and use those nuclear weapons
whether they're the Tactical nukes or
the Strategic nukes doesn't matter there
is no way to win this that would Spark
a nuclear war it would spark World War
III and the result of that is
destruction of the world it is
destruction of the world as we know it
and you know I I hate to to paint such a
bleak picture but this is people need to
know that this is the reality that we're
facing that our leaders have pushed us
and led us to this brink of nuclear war
they have their own bunkers and and ways
to protect themselves
there is no shelter for the American
people I I think it was last time I was
here I talked to you about the you know
the the nuclear scare that we had in
Hawaii and how you know this message
went out to everybody saying hey uh
missile incoming you know seek shelter
immediately this is not a drill what
everybody found out immediately is there
is no shelter there is no shelter
there's no place to go there's no place
where uh you can take your loved ones
and your kids to be protected not only
from the blast but the Fallout and the
lack of food and water and everything
else that that comes after
um uh New York uh New York City recently
put out a PSA I don't know if you saw it
but it it is literally a video ad that
they put out saying hey here's what you
do in the event of a nuclear explosion
why are they putting this out now
because of where we are as a country the
problem is as it shows in this video
their advice to the people of New York
City is get inside stay inside and stay
tuned
that's it stay tuned to what
the radio I guess I mean what is even
going to be available that's my point
that is exactly my point there will be
no power there will be no infrastructure
there will be no you know you see what's
happening in Florida right now with the
recovery efforts after uh this hurricane
just swept through and demolished it you
think about that multiply that by like I
don't know 50 000 times the devastation
is what we would see but we wouldn't
have FEMA we wouldn't have these First
Responders who are able to actually go
out and help people and the worst thing
man the worst thing I said when I
watched that PSA get inside stay inside
stay tuned at the end I'm assuming as an
actor they hired to do this she looks in
the camera and she's like you got this
New York like what in the world these
these people are creating this false
sense of security for the American
people saying like oh yeah take shelter
but there is no we should watch that
because it's so crazy it is insane we
should let's watch that because it's
it's
clear attack don't ask me how or why
just know that the big one has hit okay
so what do we do there are three
important steps that I want you to
remember
one get inside fast you your friends
your family get inside and no staying in
the car is not an option you need to get
into a building and move away from the
windows
look at her Smiles I know step two
stay inside shut all doors and windows
have a basement head there if you don't
have one get as far into the middle of
the building as possible
if you were outside after the blast get
clean immediately remove and bag all
outer clothing to keep radioactive dust
or Ash away from your body
step three stay tuned follow media for
more information don't forget to sign up
for notify NYC for official alerts and
updates
and don't go outside until officials say
it's safe all right you've got this
okay
she's gonna tell you like who's the
officials people that they elected who
who who's gonna tell you it's okay to go
outside during a nuclear blast in the
United States something that's never
happened ever and that we're completely
woefully unprepared for exactly you got
this you got this she's so pretty though
yeah she's got a nice smile got a great
smile that's probably hired her it's
that is a crazy thing to put out there
first of all because like what is it
what's the purpose of that is that to
reassure people like what is the purpose
of that yeah it's not to inform people
because none of what she said makes any
sense no oh get in the middle of the
room well that's okay right the
outside's not good just stay away in the
window the middle is not going to be
because the radiation is not just stays
put yeah it's kind of like a fog machine
yeah you know just doesn't doesn't get
inside like what I um I was in I think
it was after my second deployment uh
when I came back from the Middle East I
went on a trip and did some travel uh
through Eastern Europe and went down
actually visited Chernobyl and it was
astonishing to me even decades after
that happened because I was curious I'd
heard about it and it's like okay
um
went on this little bus and went out
there they gave us these radiation
monitors these handheld radiation
monitors so that wherever we were you
know you could kind of test and see
where the radiation still existed
they're like oh you're gonna see apple
trees and things like that don't eat any
of the fruit
because it's contaminated it is still
contaminated decades later walking
through the middle of the town I know
everyone's seen the pictures and
obviously now with that Chernobyl series
I think that Netflix did
um more and more people know the story
but
you know walking through like the school
and the classrooms where
the desks and the books and the kids
shoes and the deflated basketballs
everything is still there
um in the way that it was when people
fled and had to evacuate when that
nuclear plant melted down uh it was so
Eerie walking through there
um you could you could almost kind of
feel
feel the heaviness of of what happened
there and then as as we were leaving
after we left and were crossing back
into Ukraine
um we had to go through these like
before we got on the bus we had to go
through these radiation
um kind of like the thing you walk
through in TSA except it tests for
radiation to make sure you're not
actually bringing any contaminants with
you back into society all of that is to
say like this is what we're talking
about so you see that kind of video and
you see how completely out of touch it
is with the reality of what could happen
uh in the event in the event of a
nuclear attack and the fact that you
know Russia's got what over 6 000
nuclear warheads the United States has
over 5 000 nuclear warheads both
countries making up 90 percent of the
total number of nuclear warheads that
exist in the world
and literally it would just take the
flick of a match to spark this war off
and that's where say okay well
you hear President Biden say well this
is Putin's War this is Putin's fault
it's it's Putin who's who's who's uh the
the one who's solely responsible well
the United States and some of these
European NATO countries are fueling this
war
and need to provide the leadership to
bring about a negotiated outcome that is
exactly what needs to happen here to
prevent the destruction of the planet
and and Life as We Know It uh they're
not doing that and in doing so they are
failing the American people and putting
us in this position of
foreign
do you think that whoever the powers
would be and whatever the influence is
from the military industrial complex
that they are trying to prolong this in
order to profit so they're trying to
continue to fund Ukraine this it gives
them an excellent reason to ramp up
budgets and keep shipping over weapons
and arms they keep making more and more
profit and just get us right to the
point where it gets squirrely well Putin
won't do it he won't do it he won't do
it but if he does it there's no pulling
back from that there's the only reason
why we would ever get to that point is
because people are trying to make more
money
that is that is certainly a major driver
I have no doubt about that
I am concerned that
we may we may have passed that point uh
already
um
you're talking about people pushing us
right up right up to the line and then
just saying well you know the whole
theory of of nuclear weapons is one of
mutually assured destruction right like
there's no way Putin will ever launch
this because of that fear of like okay
well we will all be destroyed if that
happens
and they're saying you know
Putin has many things but he's not crazy
there's no way he's going to do this
well they're talking about doing it they
change their nuclear weapons policy so
that according to their laws they would
be authorized to use a nuclear weapon if
they are facing any kind of existential
threat whether it's coming from a
nuclear Source or not and and you look
at
um
the situation that that Putin is in
right now he's boxed into a corner he's
lost face he uh
he is he is in a place where he may feel
like he has nothing else to lose
and and you you you find that same kind
of mentality in people who are you know
suicidal or people who are bullied or
people who feel like they're
their best option is is a way out
and so to say to be so dismissive and
say well you know Putin's not crazy he's
not gonna he's not gonna do this
um it it denies the reality of the
position uh that he's in